[Music]
denise today more than 300
000 students back in the classroom in
clark county it went on without any
major
issues there is now a mass mandate in
schools
superintendent dr jara touring several
schools including rose warren elementary
school
that is near alta and torrey pines
principal stephanie eclairs says parents
were so excited to bring the kids back
and the school didn't have any issues
with those wearing masks
the challenge was to making sure that
the kids arrive
on campus safely and that the parents
understand our protocols and that it is
a district protocol
and that every school is trying to
enforce it the principal sporting a
raiders mask there ccsd asking parents
to monitor their kids for any coverage
symptoms
so here's the deal if there is a covid
case parents need to contact their
school nurse
who will refer them to one of six
testing sites at local schools
quarantine is being handled on a
case-by-case basis
with assistance from the health district
parents will get a personal call
if their child was exposed if a student
is vaccinated that can speed up the
quarantine process